self-confidence comes from doing  difficult things self-confidence  self-love self-respect it all comes from  deciding to do  something difficult  here's what happens when when something  hard comes up  and you find a reason why you can't do  it it's too hard it's too difficult it's  too scary  most people will let you off the hook  people around you will say yeah yeah  that's way too hard i mean the fact you  even thought about it was crazy  you let yourself off the hook  but then you realize  i could have done it  that's the worst feeling in the world  that you could have done something  but then you came up with an excuse as  to why you can't  and that will eat you up  and even if the world lets you off the  hook  recognize that they have lower standards  than you